are you telling me the crown is three
million in debt actually it's 20
trillion how could he let this happen
entitlement spending a bunch of wars
that bullet train to Riverrun didn't
help
that is a big wall mm-hmm and on the
other side are the free folk no over
here we call them wildlings right and we
hate them because why because they are
as Savage backwards knuckle-dragging
people they do whatever they please they
marry who they want they pay no taxes do
you know they don't even have a real
king just some guy they voluntarily
choose to follow their savages so they
built that wall no we built the wall
China China China China China China
China China as the invisible hand of the
king can I just suggest once again that
we do nothing Westeros is a [ __ ] show
we're massively in debt people are
starving we're constantly at war there's
an oppressive surveillance apparatus and
stifling religious dogma encroaching on
matters of State and draconian border
restrictions I mean at this point I
think it's fairly clear that we suck at
this governing thing right I am the king
again with the King stuff and then that
fault is the Social Security trust fund
where all of the money goes that will
one day be paid out to retirees
yeah it's pretty much Ponzi scheme we
all agree that winter is coming but the
answer lies in innovation not in
rationing wood and coal Baratheon sigil
a stag words ours is the fury good the
democrats sigil a donkey words it was
Russia's fault no a common saying but
not their official motto there's always
a victim Republicans sigil and elephant
words hold my beer no war walls and
Bibles no well what do they believe I
don't feel like I even know them anymore
you do know them think 9/11 libertarians
words maximizing individual liberty and
minimizing statist incursions through a
robust deployment of the non-aggression
principle in the sigil is a porcupine
humping a pile of money no swords no
daggers no crossbows of dark magic
ghosts babies no jackass blows up a sip
and now we all got to take our shoes off
and die terrorists if you have more than
6 ounces of wildfire you must place it
in a transparent plastic baggie trial by
combat will be forbidden throughout the
Seven Kingdoms the tradition is a
brutish one right but minimum sentencing
for nonviolent drug offenders that's
still a thing good people don't use milk
of the poppy dot you're such an [ __ ]
I don't know I just think blowing up a
cept in the middle of your trial feels
like obstruction of justice
so we built that wall yeah
and we paid for it oh yeah to keep out
the free folk right in there redheads
uh-huh
and now we're on this side of the wall
yeah is there like a doors probably a
big trouble endur hello is Purdue t
daenerys targaryen
Efron lumber con Delano McAfee it
shouldn't take a low-income dothraki for
years to get a hair braiding license
this is it's absurd watch does due
process mean nothing to you people I
don't care the unsullied can use
whatever bathroom they want why do we
need to get involved in this Joffrey
Cersei Walder Frey Jeff Sessions Chuck
Schumer and House Financial Services
Committee the names of every [ __ ]
person in Westeros only the ones I'm
going to kill that's what we're doing do
not I was just gonna write a letter this
[ __ ] up Aria things don't have to be
planned in order to be orderly complex
systems can evolve from natural behavior
and the result is more effective and
more efficient than anything created by
a central planner individual liberty is
a more powerful tool for prosperity than
any army any dragon or any king could
ever be I really thought this was a
libertarian
make Westeros great again no grabbed by
the poppy no big government if it's our
government no orange is the new black no
put a flag on no technically Lincoln was
a Republican ho for the children no from
each according to his ability to each
according to his need no
something-something social justice no
social justice and all caps no social
justice exclamation line public there
McCain